what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with iron man from christopher
cantwell and we are covering this point
where basically iron man has essentially
become god right where he's basically at
the powers of galactus and seemingly the
power cosmic in its totality and the
results of this is of course a little
bit of time has passed in the sense that
you have like war machine right you got
james rhodes you got the original human
torch patsy walker and all those folks
back on earth and they're kind of having
a conversation now i don't know exactly
what it is they're eating but i will say
the place around them looks pretty
crowded and if you're a person who loves
food and you are looking to just escape
the overcrowded nature of restaurants
then hello fresh is absolutely for you
so what is hellofresh well with
hellofresh you can get mouth-watering
seasonal recipes and fresh pre-measured
ingredients delivered right to your door
with hellofresh america's number one
meal kit and hellofresh makes cooking at
home fun easy and affordable and this is
important to me because i'm a busy guy
i've got social media platforms to run
i've got a business and a staff to
manage i've got a podcast network that
i'm launching what i don't want to have
to do on top of all of that is worry
about what i'm going to eat for the week
and so hellofresh makes that infinitely
easier i tell them what i want they send
it to me i take my ingredients and i
cook them no muss no fuss it's literally
the easiest thing in the world so make
sure you look in the description and use
my link or go to hellofresh.com and use
code pog comics 16 for up to 16 free
meals plus three surprise gifts across
six hello fresh boxes plus free shipping
and these three surprise gifts just so
you know they're free appetizers free
desserts and free premium recipes but
having said that let's get back into our
video
so one of the things that is easy to
i wouldn't say misinterpret but easy to
forget when it comes to the various
cosmic beings that exist out there in
marvel comics is the nature of time that
time is relative to cosmic abstracts in
fact with the exception of people like
galactus and infinity because she
represents the nature of it time doesn't
really matter the cosmic entities the
cosmic entities appearing in the year
1900 is really no different than them
appearing in the year 2000 right because
for them things just simply exist right
i mean there is a point whereby the
universe will begin and the universe
will end but marvel never really gives
us this idea that cosmic entities really
care about the concept of time and for
someone like tony stark right when he
had undergone the process of
experiencing what it meant to undertake
the power cosmic to have that power
given to him and then go through the
whole process of being imbued with it
that time had passed but we were never
really given how much time had passed
because that's designed to kind of
mirror how the cosmic entities see
existence right just a seemingly series
of successive moments but no real
differentiation between how much time
passes between each individual moment
it's just a series of things that take
place it kind of makes sense not a super
important thing but it's good to see
that christopher camwell sort of notices
this but of course at that point tony
stark does arrive on earth and when he
shows up here it's very reminiscent to
how you would expect galactus to appear
or character that imposing now it's also
kind of feeding into the ego of tony
stark a little bit and in fact what he
does with this power is kind of funny
here in a little while because he
shrinks down to a more reasonable size
right that people can kind of comprehend
and they don't necessarily find so
intimidating and then in the midst of
all that as he's talking to james rose
there's not really much of a
conversation here right like he's
literally there for like two seconds the
avengers show up alongside the fantastic
four and the funny thing here is that
they don't quite know what to make of
tony stark and the reason why is because
while tony has done some things a lot of
them are also familiar with the things
that tony has done right so say for
example the idea of the infinity
gauntlet one of the things a lot of you
guys may not know is iron man's had the
infinity gauntlet and in fact iron man
got the infinity gauntlet off of parker
robbins the hood when the hood got the
infinity gauntlet now of course the
other members of the illuminati knew
what was going on because tony stark
taking it and then telling everybody
else who was there uh these gems need to
be taken care of it's too dangerous all
that kind of stuff was really him taking
it and then the illuminati splitting the
gems among themselves but the important
thing is they know how shady tony stark
can be and when you take like the
shadiness of tony stark and then you
combine it with basically godly power
who knows what he's going to do and
that's one of those things where like
they start to question like what are
your motivations here right is michael
korvac still a threat of course at the
end of the day he's like you know
michael korvac is basically defeated but
when captain america asks the question
well what about you are you a threat his
response is well that sounds awfully
loaded and steve's like i'm very
concerned and so in the end his response
is i mean can you relax right we've all
dealt with gods before look at thor
right it's the exact same five and
thor's like no we're not i'm totally
different here
this is a whole different thing and so
the big question people have is what's
tony stark going to do with this power
and so what he does is he makes this
amazing speech right this amazing
impassioned thing and he says okay well
korvac was right and wanting harmony but
wrong about how to get there he believed
that he alone knew best he put himself
and his opinions above others and then
he asked him he has the avengers he's
like doesn't that sound familiar to you
guys and he says korvac was wrong to
hoard his intellect wrong to want to
take away free will from everyone else i
had the infinity gems once but i wasn't
going to force anything with them and i
won't now either but then how does one
make something harmonious while
preserving the individual and he says
well i looked at my own gifts i'm
talking about the things i had before
these new powers i thought of solutions
and ideas i've had in the past and how
they've gone awry and i realized
something they didn't work because they
were trapped in here in my head but now
what's in here doesn't have to be
trapped inside anymore it can be shared
as a gift now the funny thing about this
is that there's a kind of irritable
moment that takes place right and this
is the thing that kind of gives people
pause for concern is that captain
america keeps interrupting iron man and
saying wait like hold on man like here's
the thing and as iron man is trying to
make his point captain america keeps
interrupting him trying to trying to
literally make his case and the response
of iron man is let me finish right and
just kind of like gross to this huge
size now understand this is not iron man
getting carried away with his power this
is iron man being pissed with captain
america because the point that iron man
was making up until this moment is that
there's a kind of hubris that comes with
the avengers yes they're as much street
level heroes as they are the earth's
mightiest heroes saving earth from
various threats and saving some guy
random guy on the street who's being
mugged by somebody else but there's a
hubris in the avengers in the sense that
because they're superheroes and because
they've saved the earth from so many
threats and they do good things they
know what's best and so captain america
in the eyes of iron man embodies that
hubris more than anything else i'm
captain america i've been around for a
long long time i have great battle
strategy and i know how to organize and
galvanize the superhero community
everyone should listen to me right that
kind of irritation now of course a lot
of it's also just because these guys
have just had a sketchy history ever
since the events of civil war but what
iron man says here is my gift is now in
all of you my intellect my level of
aptitude it's yours you are all now
stark level geniuses but it's kind of a
funny thing because the whole question
here is well what if we don't want it
and he's like well i mean it's too late
right it's done you're all now as
brilliant as i am and so is every living
person in the city and he says i figured
we'd start with a small sample size and
see how it goes he says i don't want
things to get too far ahead right i
don't want this experiment to be
something that i effectively lose
control of and the funny thing here is
susan asks reed she's like what do you
think reid like do you feel any
different he's like actually i feel like
i just became less intelligent
but all across the city of new york
right queens these different places that
you have these arguments that are going
on between couples right between people
and as they engage in these arguments as
soon as this power is given suddenly
it's a series of like introspection well
i'm saying this to you because i am
actually feeling this way but i'm not
telling you i'm feeling this way because
you know and so on and so forth it's
people kind of coming to terms with what
they're really thinking and then voicing
what it is they're really thinking not
only that it's people becoming geniuses
like in the boardroom offering solutions
that hadn't really been given before
right throwing out these things like
carbon based nano quadrature that
atomizes the hydrogen into particles of
energy and i don't even know what that
means but the thing about this is that
people are basically just incredibly
intelligent and this is a really really
interesting concept because what this
does here is it's tony stark showing up
to the world and saying i am not going
to make the world better i'm going to
give the world the opportunity to make
itself better i'm going to give people
the opportunity the means the
intelligence to improve the world and to
make it a better place and so it's a
genius idea because what you do is you
effectively box people in right you box
humanity in you take this section of new
york and you say okay with everybody
becoming more intelligent now if this
place doesn't get better it's because
people don't want it to get better
because with this level of intelligence
this is going to have to lead to
compromise because people will realize
okay my particular solution won't work
perfectly but maybe a blending of five
solutions will right just things along
those lines now of course the funny
thing about this is that at that moment
you basically have big wheel who just
wakes up out of a coma right now as far
as i'm aware big wheel ended up in a
coma because you know the events of
deadpool and the merch for money number
four i don't really know a whole lot
about this guy i mean the guy is
literally driving like a giant big wheel
through the city of new york right just
seemingly causing all kinds of of crazy
commotion and pandemonium and it looks
like he's just using his intelligence to
engage in like some villainous schemes
of course the entire time this is going
on iron man is effectively being yelled
at by patsy walker like are you really
sure that this is a good thing to do
right i mean you're basically taking
what you deem to be the right thing to
do and then imposing it across the world
and so on and so forth but then like big
wheel basically gets their attention and
this guy is just like running through
and causing all kinds of crazy things
and the funny thing about that is like
like patsy walker's like is big wheel
typically a technologically organized
maniac wielding selenium encoded
infrared signal beams and you know i
understood some of those words and like
the response of iron man is like no he's
usually just a guy in a big wheel
and here's the funny thing about this is
that once they finally catch up to him
and once they finally stop him they
realize that while he does shoot patsy
walker in order to make her get out of
the way which is a kind of a dick thing
to do it's a villainous thing to do iron
man of course brings the whole thing to
a halt and then realizes that what big
wheel was doing was solving the problem
of traffic issues in new york he was
solving the problem of gridlock right
like he literally fixed all the traffic
problems in new york city that people
can basically travel throughout the
entirety of the city as you would in a
normal place right in a normal location
he says hey this guy just solved traffic
congestion that's truly groundbreaking
man
that's a pretty big deal and so it's one
of those funny things is because this is
how some people are basically going to
use their powers right and so as a
result of this what you get here is
patsy walker screaming at iron man right
and where iron man's trying to plead the
case and sing like look like what i'm
doing here is working you're welcome
like what else do you want from me her
response is how about some foresight the
world doesn't simply become instantly
better just because we all think like
you do now and of course that pisses off
iron man who in turn says even with the
incredible capacity of my mind you
whimper with small minded doubt i will
fix this entire world just watch me and
in that moment patsy walker's like
there's nothing to do and so patsy
walker basically just walks off and so
as a result of this she goes to the only
person that she really can go to when
you're dealing with someone with just
incredible levels of intelligence and
power only one man is capable of
bringing that person down someone of
equal intelligence and equal aspirations
for high levels of power she goes to
victor von doom and says you need to be
the one to bring iron man back down to
our level to well in all honesty you
need to be the one to stop iron man from
trying to fix the world but with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this video to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace